تاويلات كثيره يحتملها الموقف الالماني
الاخير بشان الدبابات اليو بارتو حيث تلام
برلين على بطء التعامل مع المازق رغم حاجه
اوكرانيا المتزايده لتمكين قدرتها
الهجوميه لكن ما هو السبب لهذا التردد
واشنطن بوست مشاهدينا اكدت ان المانيا
تعاني من صدمه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مضيفه ان مزيج العار والذم اثر العقود
بصناع القرار الالمانيين وفق الصحيفه
واوضحت ان الحكومه لا تريد ان تستخدم
الاسلحه الالمانيه على الخطوط الاماميه في
مناطق الصراع ثقافه الحذر العسكري لبرلين
او المخاوف المتعلقه باحتمال استفزاز
روسيا وحصول تصعيد في النساء احدى الاسباب
المتداوله ايضا اسباب وصفها نائب وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني بالواهيه وغير
المنطقيه هذا الحذر العسكري سمح لشخصيات
اوروبيه انتقدت سابقا وان تقدت ايضا الى
التوجه للصداره من الناحيه الاخلاقيه
كرئيس الوز البولندي مثلا الاخير ده عاشود
الى اتخاذ اجراء حازم مضيفا انه على
المانيا ان تقرر ان كانت تريد الوقوف على
الجبهه الخاطئه من التاريخ المفارقه هي ان
المانيا واحده من اكبر موردي الاسلحه
والمساعدات الى كياب بعد الولايات المتحده
منذ بدء الحرب
الالمان سريعا هذه المره لان الالمانيه
تاخرون ويتهربون ويتصرفون بطريقه يصعب
فهمها يمكننا ان نرى بوضوح شديد انهم لا
يريدون مساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
نفسها على نطاق اوسع بالطبع سنه تقدم بطلب
لسداد فاتوره الدبابات الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وينبغي على الاتحاد الاوروبي
تعويضنا عن هذه التكاليف واملوا ان يحدث
ذلك